do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for the official game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer breakdown video that's
right folks we finally got a new trailer
from HBO so without wasting anyone's
time let's break this down frame by
frame because there is a lot to unpack
here the trailer actually begins with a
close-up of Arya Starks face it looks
like this could be a scene during the
big battle in Winterfell
as you can see Arya is scared covered in
sweat out of breath and running around
the castle as we see Arya running
through the castle we can hear some of
her dialogue overlapping the scene Arya
Stark says I know death he's got many
faces I look forward to seeing this one
right as she says that she holds up what
appears to be a dragon glass dagger I
would like to say that Arya has to be
talking to either bran or John during
that scene when she holds up the dagger
that means Arya is definitely referring
to the night King which most likely
explains why we see Arya scared and
running at the very beginning of the
trailer now I will say Arya should be
careful what she wishes for because she
may have seen death before but she has
never seen anything quite like this so
what does all this mean well it can only
mean one thing
the night king is most likely on the
verge of winning the first battle at
Winterfell
unfortunately the Starks may have to
abandon their ancestral home for at
least a short period of time for any of
you wondering this should take place
right in the middle of the season during
episode 3 which is directed by Miguel
supports Nick that is the same man who
directed Hart home in the Battle of the
bastards some of you may not know this
but there are secret tunnels under
Winterfell that could allow the starts
to escape their castle if it gets over
ran by the night king's army we have
heard about the secret tunnels on two
different occasions this could also
explain why they release that teaser
about the crypts of Winterfell if they
do have to leave their castle they will
need to go down into the crypts
wonderful to access those tunnels by the
looks of that teaser the night King and
the White Walkers could be following
them down there that could also explain
why we see Arya Stark running during
that opening scene of the trailer but
now let's move on to some of the other
scenes we can also see Davos walking
along a top of the castle walls and I
would say this is most likely right
before the night Kings army arrives in
Winterfell
we then see Varys and a large group of
people hiding down in the crypts of
Winterfell if you look at the back of
the photo you can see the large statues
what the stone direwolves so it appears
as if they are hiding down here during
the battle for Winterfell we can see
Varys looking somewhat scared as he
looks up at the ceiling he probably
hears all the chaos taking place right
above him it does make sense for them to
hide down here because as I said before
access to those hidden tunnels is down
here as well after these scenes we
finally leave Winterfell for the first
time in the trailer in this scene we can
see some of your on Greyjoy ships this
is when we get our first glimpse of the
golden company and I have to be honest
with you at first glance I almost
thought that was Jaime Lannister
standing above all the other soldiers
but on second thought I have to assume
that is the commander of the golden
company Harry Strickland as we all know
Cersei acquired 20,000 mercenaries from
Essos and they are currently on their
way to King's Landing thanks to your own
Greyjoy's escort they should arrive at
the capital in either the first or the
second episode of this season after we
see the golden company on their way to
Westeros we then see Lord Commander edy
tormund Giantsbane and beric Dondarrion
so we can now confirm they did survive
the attack at eastwatch-by-the-sea not
only that but they did find their way to
Castle black to team up with the rest of
the Nights Watch which is something I
have said they would do now it is hard
to say where tormund barrack and EDD are
at in that scene beric Dondarrion is
lighting their way with this flaming
sword so it's possible they could be
entering an empty castle that has no
candles lit if they are not Winterfell
in that scene that my guess is they are
on their way there this could be the car
hold or the last hearth but I'm not
entirely sure
now the next scene has me very excited
because we can hear brains start talking
to who I think is Jon Snow in the scene
we can see bran stark sitting with
Samwell Tarly but we also see Samuel
Tarley turn his head to the door so that
means that someone is most likely
walking into the bedroom based on what
we can hear brains start talking about
it has to be John Snow brain stark says
everything you did brought you where you
are now where you belong as a brain
stark says where you belong they show an
image of the Red Keep and King's Landing
now we know Jon Snow is the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne so this is most
likely when brain is telling John who he
truly is
then after brain says where you belong
he says home that's when we see John and
Danny marching to Winterfell together
this is the scene they have been teasing
for several months now this scene is
said to be very reminiscent of King
Robert Baratheon's arrival to Winterfell
in the opening scene of the series now
this time brain is not climbing the
castle as he sees the arrival but he is
sitting atop the wall as he sees John
and Danny approaching Shawn's a stark is
up there as well and this is when we see
Daenerys Targaryen dragons arrive at
Winterfell for the first time Shaun's a
stark gets a great look at the dragons
up close as they fly right over her head
after we see the dragons fly over
Winterfell we then hear a speech from
Jon Snow and he is also talking about
the night king and his army coming John
says they're coming our enemy doesn't
get tired doesn't stop doesn't feel now
let's unpack all these scenes they show
as we hear Jon Snow's speech the first
thing we see is Jon and Daenerys down in
the crypts of Winterfell it did look
like Jon was already down there first
because we can see Daenerys walking to
him in that first shot then it cuts to
Daenerys standing right next to Jon
now this could just simply be Jon down
here visiting Ned for a number of
reasons but I would like to think this
happens right after Brian tells Jon who
he really is
this should make for one very
interesting scene for two different
reasons
not only will Daenerys find out jon is
the one that has the rightful claim but
this could also be when Jon finds out
the nurse is pregnant with his child
their emotions may be running very high
during that scene they will need to
decide what they want to do with their
relationship from here on out and who
should take the Iron Throne after we see
John and Danny down in the crypts of
Winterfell we then see ginjury working
in Winterfell forges now this is what
ginjury was supposed to be
last season but as we all know he
volunteered to go out beyond the wall
instead I imagine this is what gun jury
will be doing until the night King
arrives this also means that aria and
gun jury had to have reunited as well
what you all know that is one scene that
I am dying to see now we all know that
John mind all the dragonglass from the
caves on Dragonstone almost everyone
should have a dragon glass dagger next
season but that is not the only weapon
we can see Gendry makin in the trailer I
don't know if you noticed or not began
jury was laying that hammer down onto
some steel it looks like den jury will
be making some swords next season as
well and that has me very excited could
Gendry just be making swords out of
regular steel or could he possibly be
working on some Valyrian steel now I
don't want to get ahead of myself but I
did want to point that out alright so
after we see gunn jury we then begin to
see the battle at Winterfell unfold the
castle has now erupted in chaos we can
see Jorah Mormont on horseback and we
can see grey worm give him a sand a a
kiss and we even see Jaime Lannister
fighting call me crazy but it even
looked like Jaime was fighting with his
sword hand now I can't see who Jaime is
standing next to but it does appear as
if the castle was on fire to some extent
this was almost guaranteed to happen
because we all know there are dragons
fighting in that battle Winterfell will
take some significant damage next season
which may be why the Starks have to
leave their castle before it completely
Falls now let's continue earlier in the
trailer we could see Cersei and Qyburn
standing outside the castle where Jaime
and Cersei stood last season when you're
on Greyjoy first arrived this is most
likely a very similar scene only this
time you're on is arriving with the
golden company which we can see in the
next scene it might be hard for some of
you to see but if you look closely you
can see the commander of the golden
company standing right in front of the
iron throne
Joran Greyjoy who is dressed in all
black is standing to his right this has
to be right after they arrived in the
capital and I am expecting Cersei to
tell him what she wants all of them to
do however if you look at the next scene
it doesn't look like the golden company
will be enough next we can see Cersei
Lannister drinking some wine and by this
time Cersei must no longer be
or else she would not be drinking that
wine I happen to believe Cersei will
have a miscarriage
as we all know Maggy the Frog told her
she would only have three children and
that is what I believe to be true now
this is just a guess but I think that
scene could be from the end of the
season I just get that sense that this
is right before Cersei is killed you can
already see that she does have tears in
her eyes now maybe she is crying because
she just lost her child but I think this
could also be right before King's
Landing is taken from her as we all know
it's only a matter of time before that
happened we have all known this was
coming ever since the second season when
we saw Daenerys Targaryen vision at the
house of the undying Cersei Lannister
was good enough to outlast most of her
enemies but she too will fall like the
rest of them now after this we get some
more scenes of John and Danny arriving
in Winterfell the first thing we see are
the Dragons flying through the north
then we can see Arya looking at the
dragons for the first time as everyone
runs behind her Arya has a slight smile
come across her face getting to see the
dragons in real life as are very excited
and I am looking forward to Arya and
Daenerys meeting next season after this
we can hear Jaime Lannister talking to
someone and I believe this is when Jaime
arrives in Winterfell to help Jon and
Daenerys fight the army of the Dead
Jaime says I promise to fight for the
living and I intend to keep that promise
we did see Jaime Lannister fighting in
the trailer so we do know that they
accept his offer to still fight with
them we then get a shot at grey worm
getting suited and booted for the big
battle then we see Jon Snow standing out
by the weirwood tree and winterfell's
gods would this is most likely another
scene where Jon stands alone so he can
reflect on everything that he has been
told he has to come to terms with the
fact that he is actually a Targaryen and
that he is a next in line for the Iron
Throne he might also be thinking about
the fact that he will be a father soon
like I said in my last video I believe
Daenerys is without a doubt pregnant by
Jon Snow
I think they foreshadowed this way too
many times last season for it not to be
true we can even see Daenerys standing
in one of the rooms at Winterfell and we
see her close her eyes so she is most
likely thinking about everything that is
happening between her and
like I said I am very interested in
seeing how all of this plays out because
I wonder what this will do to John and
Danny's relationship from here on out
now I want to talk about the next scene
in this one we get a close-up of sandor
clegane face this could just simply be a
shot of the helm getting ready to fight
at Winterfell but I am hoping it is
something more than that
I am hoping this is right as the Hound
is about to challenge his brother to a
fight to the death
after this we start to see a bunch of
different characters running around it's
really too hard to say what is exactly
happening in these scenes but my guess
is this is when the night king is
starting to win the battle at Winterfell
causing everyone to flee the battlefield
next we can see Jon and Daenerys walking
up to the dragons now I am hoping this
is after John finds out he is a
Targaryen I would love to see Jon
actually climb on top of Rygel the
dragon named after his father and
Daenerys Targaryen 's brother we have
already seen jaw and start to bond to a
drug on once as soon as John starts to
fully embrace who he is then I imagine
he will have the confidence to try to
mount Ragle now we all know that John
can kick some ass on the battlefield but
they could get so much more done if both
of the dragons had riders this could
also help prevent Ragle from getting
taken out of the sky by another one of
those damn ice Spears now the next scene
is a little harder for me to figure out
here we can see Arya Stark spinning
around in circles fighting someone or
something but I can't exactly see what
the hell is going on here I did watch it
a few times and I still can't figure it
out now it is most likely during the
battle in Winterfell but for all I know
it could be in King's Landing let me
know what you think about that one after
that we see tyrion lannister looking up
into the sky this immediately cuts to a
scene of the dragon breathing fire but
they are not the same scenes we can see
that it's daytime when tyrion is looking
up at the sky in its night time when the
dragon spits out its fire now maybe
tyrion is looking at john riding on ray
golf for the first time or maybe tyrion
is looking up at the Red Keep and King's
Landing
it's really hard to say but I do not
think tyrion is getting killed by a
dragon in that particular scene I just
wanted to say that because I saw some
fans on Twitter saying that was what was
happening but I do not agree with that
now the trailer ends with the battle for
went
fell we can see all of our favorite
character standing in formation waiting
for the attack to begin it is completely
silent as they wait for the knight King
to arrive the last shot of this trailer
actually gave me goosebumps because I
know this battle is about to be epic we
can see Winterfell just off in the
distance as one of the White Walkers
horses comes into frame we do not hear
the knight king's dragon but you can bet
your ass he is right over their head
this is about to be absolutely insane I
cannot wait to hear what all of you have
to say about these scenes leave your
thoughts down below in the comment
section let me know if there was
anything I missed
trust me this will not be the only video
I make about the trailer I will continue
to watch it over and over again hoping
to mine it for some more gold anyways I
want to thank all of you for watching
today's video
make sure you subscribe that way you can
see all of the upcoming videos about the
final season a Game of Thrones
hopefully I see all of you come back for
the next ones have a great day I'll see
you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]